today on the matt welsh show a very
special announcement coming up in just a
second and also democrats have already
defunded police departments across the
country
amid a surge in violent crime now
they've unveiled their brilliant next
step
stop building jails because that will
surely solve the crime problem and five
headlines including
women inmates speaking of jails and
former inmates speaking out about men
being put in cells with them
uh where where is the compassionate left
on that plus
katie hill sues various media outlets
over the nude photos of her that they
published and she loses the case now she
has to pay
100 000 uh what do we think about that
and more information comes out about the
ufos that infest our skies are they
really
technology from outer space or from
foreign adversaries
and if they are from foreign adversaries
should we be concerned that our own
military is more focused on diversity
and inclusion
than on defending our nation all of that
and more today on the matt wall show
before we begin today i want to revisit
something briefly that we discussed
yesterday
alexandria casey cortez posted pictures
of her abuela's dilapidated home in
puerto rico
blaming the trump administration for the
squalid conditions that her grandmother
is forced to live in now
i and plenty of other people pointed out
that perhaps
aoc herself being a wealthy and famous
politician
might want to reach into her own pocket
and help her poor abuela you would think
she has
more than enough resources to do that
but we have to understand that aoc
has other expenses that she has to
attend to
she just bought a tesla for example you
know those those payments can be pretty
expensive
and she spends a lot i'm sure on organic
produce at whole foods have you ever
seen
the organic produce section at whole
foods very expensive
she just the point is she just isn't
able to fix her abuela's
ceiling which is currently in the
process of collapsing that's why she
posted a picture of it and blamed donald
trump for it
and i understand all of that
and i want to help so today i'm going to
be launching a gofundme campaign to help
aoc's abuela
and this is totally serious we're really
going to launch this
and i'll be kicking off the effort by
donating some of my own money
to this effort you know i'll have more
information about the fundraising drive
very soon but for now i you know i i
just want
aoc's abuela to know that that i care
even if her grand daughter doesn't help
is on the way
more on on that later on today um now
on to the topic at hand as we know there
is an epidemic
of violent crime all across the country
this epidemic is
really just an extension of a worsening
of the epidemic that had already been
plaguing many major cities for decades
as democrats move to defund police
departments release prisoners from jail
or keep them out of jail to begin with
many cities are seeing their already
existent violent crime problem
surge now to terrifying new levels
selecting just a few examples here
homicides in los angeles are up 44
from 2019 and nearly 27 over 2020
aggravated assaults and other violent
crimes have also
seen a precipitous rise violent crime in
new york is up 22
in seattle they're dealing with their
highest homicide rate in over a quarter
century
in chicago shootings are up 36 36
over the previous year and they were
really bad the previous year too
atlanta baltimore austin et cetera have
all seen similar spikes
as incarceration rates go down and the
prison population decreases
and police departments shrink violent
crime rises
it's almost as if there might be some
kind of correlation here i don't know
fewer people in prison prison
populations going down
fewer police officers crime is going up
there there's just a lot of dots here
that seem to be collecting and it's
almost like you could
you might be able to connect them i
don't know
in fact there are more dots than that
that possibly could be
connected because there's a very
specific pattern to some of this stuff
so take just the latest and this is the
latest one one of the latest ones uh the
latest random assault against an asian
person this one was in new york first
let's play the local news report on the
incident and maybe you can pick up on
some of the patterns that are coming to
light here let's watch
a monday night on memorial day a
55-year-old asian woman was returning
from grocery shopping
when she was suddenly punched the victim
fell to the ground on her butt
and rolled back the back of her head hit
the outdoor dining frame
and she passed out her eye just shut off
thankfully good samaritans stepped in to
tend to the victim and to make sure the
attacker did not
escape police arrested 48-year-old
alexander wright and charged him with
assault as a hate crime
records show wright who was homeless has
been arrested
17 times a history of alleged violence
a pattern of going right back on the
street
so what's the pattern well first of all
um there that was not a white man
committing that assault asians are being
targeted across the country but despite
what the media might want you to believe
this wave of hate crimes
is not being driven by white
supremacists
but the other noticeable pattern is that
the man had collected
arrests like their trophies 17 prior
arrests several of them for violent
crimes
yet he ends up back on the street after
each crime never with apparently any
intention
to stop committing crimes
just put him back on the street you know
he's going to commit another crime and
he does and
repeat the process forever
this is a violent criminal known to the
system
as a violent criminal and yet allowed to
remain on the street
victimizing innocent people and you
notice this with
most of the attacks we've heard about uh
these attacks against asian people
most of the cases we've heard about most
of the time
it's someone who's been randomly
assaulting people for years like a hobby
we noticed this with many of blm's
criminal martyrs
men who had committed one crime after
another and yet were still on the street
so what's the answer to this problem
well not to give her the stage
yet again as i did in my opening
monologue
yesterday but um it's not my fault that
she keeps saying stupid things so what
can i do
aoc has an idea which she explained
during a press conference yesterday this
is her idea
for what we can do about all the crime
this is what she says
if we want to reduce violent crime if we
want to reduce the number of people in
our jails
the answer is to stop building more of
them the answer
is to make sure that we actually build
more hospitals we pay organizers
we get people mental health care and
overall health care
employment etc it's to support
communities not throw them away
yeah first of all i will be expecting a
press conference like that
to thank me for the for the the help
that i'll be giving her
abuela um i'm not gonna hold my breath
but
she says the answer to crime is to stop
building jails sure just as the answer
to obesity is to stop manufacturing
scales
the answer to kidney disease is to tear
down the dialysis clinics
the answer to paralysis is to stop
making wheelchairs
you know if you don't have um if you
don't have the thing
that is meant to address a certain
problem then you no longer have the
problem
apparently i also threw out a bottle of
tylenol yesterday and it cured my
headache
it's amazing how this works the problem
of course
is that uh in reality if you have fewer
jails and fewer people in jails
the people who would otherwise be in
jail
have to go somewhere and in this case
they will go back into their communities
where they will become the problem of
someone other than aoc
or her fellow democratic lawmakers
always remember
that the people telling us to tear down
the jails and the police departments
they are almost every time in nearly
every case
people who live in communities where
violent crime is not a major issue to
begin with
it's easy for them to have compassion
for violent criminals
because someone else will have to pay
the price for their compassion
and you'll notice that about democratic
leftist compassion this is the way it
always goes
someone suffers because of it and it's
not them
now true compassion means taking on
someone's suffering
sharing in their suffering suffering
alongside them
it means that you as the compassionate
person
are the ones suffering alongside the the
person
but that's not how leftist compassion
works
see you will suffer for their compassion
your family pays the price your children
they're not alleviating injustice or
suffering
they are at best transferring it from
one place to another
and never on to themselves because
they're standing off at a safe distance
only in this case there is no injustice
in sending criminals to jail there may
be some suffering for them
sure i imagine there's a lot of
suffering in jail
but um they deserve it
their suffering is just if you're a
criminal
especially a violent criminal and you
suffer in jail
you deserve it your suffering is earned
i'll even say this your suffering is
good it is good
for violent criminals to suffer
it's good even for them criminals should
suffer
we should make them suffer they should
pay a price for their crimes
no but what democrats say is they
shouldn't suffer you should
this is not compassion it's sociopathy
so what's the real answer to violent
crime well i mean what should
we really do about it what policies
should we put in place
well how about this radical idea just
try to stay with me on this
we could arrest the criminals
put them in prison and keep them there
three-step process i mean really it's
two steps
arrest the criminals put them in prison
and then they stay there
so you punish them you make them suffer
for their crimes make them pay the price
and make the price a steep one
how's that for a novel concept how is
that for reform
you want reform that's what the reform
should be
now let's get to our five headlines
now we check in with ziprecruiter you
know recent data shows that out of all
the female owned businesses it's
estimated that one in three
is owned by a mom not the same mom but i
mean
they're all different moms presumably
ever wonder how these amazing moms and
dads find time to hire for their
businesses while juggling their families
well with zip recruiter
that's how they do it and right now you
can try it for free only at
ziprecruiter.com
walsh ceo and founder talia goldstein is
one such
entrepreneur besides being a mother of
two her personalized matchmaking company
three-day rule is constantly growing and
she needs to hire several matchmakers
a month so that's why she uses zip
recruiter zip recruiters powerful
technology
helps her find people with the right
experience and actively invites them to
apply
so it's not just like you're putting the
listing up and hoping that someone finds
it
they are actively finding people for you
to fill that job four out of the five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the first day
you just can't beat those kinds of
results
and right now you could try zip
recruiter for free at this web address
ziprecruiter.com walsh this special
offer is only good at ziprecruiter.com
walsh w-a-l-s-h zip recruiter the
smartest way to hire
okay uh and i i the other big news of
course is
if you're watching uh the video podcast
on youtube or on daily wire i'm sure
you've noticed
my uh wonderful shirt
which says the end is near with a ufo on
it
um i don't know if you see this is why
we need the the second camera angle
because that really gives you the shot
of the shirt i don't know if you can get
it in the main camera but this is we
should
just stay with this camera the entire
show just to get the shirt
in the shot uh now my my wife
bought this shirt for me she actually
bought it for me on her birthday because
she went out shopping on her birthday
and she bought me something it was
i didn't plan that she just did and um
she
originally told me because i said i
wanted to wear this shirt on the show
and she told me that i better give her
credit for buying it for me
um but then she came back a few minutes
later and said well never mind i don't
want people to
think that i agree with you on the alien
stuff because i don't
so she wants that to be made clear what
will be really funny though
is um is if she doesn't want anyone to
think she wants she wants
people to to know that like the alien
thing is all me
it is not shared in the family it is not
it it is not a it is not a
mental illness that the whole family
shares but it'd be really funny if um
people went on twitter and tagged my
wife
and said like hey uh i heard you're a
big fan of aliens
i heard you're a big believer welcome to
the club that kind of thing
that'd be funny um all right
let's start here we got a bunch of
headlines today we might end up with
more than five i don't know i gotta go
we
had a lot of some leftover ones i want
to get through all these before the week
is over
so we'll start with this a pretty big
headline i think a very important
message on mental and physical health
that uh i want to share with you well in
fact the government wanted to share with
us and i'm going to share it with you
this is an important message on mental
and physical health from
your very own assistant health secretary
who is an expert on both subjects
listen to this throughout my career i
have focused
on the intersection between medical
mental and behavioral health and as your
ash
i will continue that focus and support
policy initiatives to improve americans
physical and mental well-being
there's the message first of all as your
what
as you it sounded like as your ass but
um but i'm assuming
assistant secretary of health okay that
makes sense anyway
um so a uh a person who
is a morbidly obese
male who identifies as a woman
is um an expert now on
mental and physical health
maybe i don't need to go into any
greater detail in uh
you know discussing the irony of this
you could probably fill in the blanks
yourself
and we can continue uh next we have this
from the daily wire
former and current female inmates
speaking of uh prison populations former
and current female inmates from liberal
states like california washington are
speaking out
about gender laws which allow
biologically male inmates who identify
as female to share prison cells with
them
one woman recalled sharing and this gets
a little graphic by the way just a fair
warning but
i think everyone needs to know what's
going on here
so um a little graphic but one woman
recalled sharing a cell with a man
who sustained quote a full erection
another noted how female inmates
um many victims of past sexual assault
are arming themselves out of fear of
victimization from
300 pound men who quote look like
hercules
those women spoke to abigail schreier
author of irreversible damage the
transgender craze seducing our daughters
a book which i read recently and i've
talked about on this show and i would
highly recommend that book to everyone
um
but they spoke with her and she she was
she was talking about their their plight
former inmate tyrina griffin told
schreier that quote many of the men who
are transferring there
aren't even on hormonal uh medication
she told the author quote they're
getting a full erection so you're locked
in this room
24 7 with a man and there's nothing you
can do about it
if you tell the police you don't want to
live with a man or you're afraid or
whatever
you'll get a disciplinary infraction so
you're basically punished for being
scared
another former inmate amy ichikawa
explained that central california
women's facility
in chowchilla does not separate inmates
based
on severity of crime due to the nature
of women's facilities being
significantly less violent
than men's facilities so when
biologically male
inmates are transferred in they're mixed
with inmates without regard to the
nature of their crime
ichikawa said quote we're all mixed
together the people who've murdered
their children are in the same room as
the people who've stolen boxers
from walmart and uh it's it's worth
reading this report because it goes into
more detail than that
and all of it is absolutely horrifying
now
i said just a moment ago that
prisons are a place of suffering there's
no doubt about that
and that's not a bad thing because if
you're a criminal you should suffer
all criminals should suffer just not to
the same degree i mean obviously someone
who
steals boxers from walmart isn't going
to suffer it shouldn't be made to suffer
in the same way that
a violent criminal or murderer should
but there should be
a punishment yeah that's the thing with
with
uh now now i'm kind of backtracking to
the other conversation we'll loop back
around in a second but
we have to be clear and i think we have
this muddled idea these days about what
prison even
is and why it exists in the first place
and i would say that it exists for two
reasons and they're equally as important
one reason is to segregate dangerous
people from society
that that's part of it that's really
important especially if you live in one
of these communities where these violent
criminals tend to uh
tend to also live but we can't forget
the other part of it
is punishment it is an actual punishment
and part of being punished is suffering
and that is good again for society it
helps to maintain a properly ordered
society
it helps to keep society safe there's
also a deterrent
element to it but it's good for the for
the criminal
to have to suffer and to confront the
severity of their own crimes and that's
how if there's any chance of
reconciliation if there's any chance of
of personal reform of turning a new leaf
it's not going to happen
unless uh the people who commit these
crimes are made to suffer so
so there that's that there should be
suffering in prison
but there's also a concept of cruel and
unusual punishment
which is in our constitution and that's
a good thing
because as i said there's a limit and
there are degrees of suffering
and this is all supposed to be
calibrated based on the severity of
crime and everything
so putting women many of them not even
violent criminals
you know shoplifters
illegal drug users and so on locking
them
in cells with with these
large violent men for 24 hours a day
that is cruel and unusual punishment it
is unconstitutional
it is a it's a a horrifying
form of torture and neglect
and these women are being literally
science we hear so much about
well women are being silenced in most
cases that's
not the case at all most of the women
who are out screaming that they're being
silenced well
they're screaming and we hear them so
they're not being silenced
but these women in prison they are
literally being silenced
as we heard from one of them one of them
said if they if they speak out against
it or if they object
if they say hey um this is a this is a
dude you've just put me in a
prison cell with this is a dude who
isn't even making an effort
to pretend that he's a woman if they say
that they're gonna they get punished for
it
if you care if you really cared at all
about number one women's rights
and number two um the the
unjust suffering and the unjust
punishment
of of criminals if you cared about any
of that
or all of it then you'd be speaking out
loudly about this
you'd be holding press conferences about
this
alexandria case of cortez she's not
going to say a damn word about this is
it because she doesn't know oh she knows
is it because she doesn't realize that
it's insane
to be putting taking women and putting
them in prison jail cells with
with 300 pound men
does she not real no she realizes that
it's insane also
despite how it may seem most of these
democrats including alexandria
quesadilla cortez
look they're radical they're dishonest
um but they're most of them are not
stupid
you know they may they may seem like
they are but they're they're they're at
least they're not as dumb as they come
across
they know what they're doing
and they know that this is wrong but
they're not going to say anything about
it because they care more about their
ideology
than the suffering of anyone including
women
and all of this is based on you know
we're putting men
in women's prisons it's based on the
honor system
like you you might as well just uh
have no bars and no walls in the prison
and and base the entire thing on the
honor system
you know here's your here's your spot
where you're supposed to be in jail for
the next 27 years
we're not going to have any guards we're
not going to have any any walls or
anything honor system okay
i mean you're you're a murderer i'm sure
you i'm sure i'm sure we can trust your
personal
sense of honor and integrity so on the
honor system
they're letting men into women's prisons
because the men claim that they identify
as women or really
feel deep down that they're women
there's there's no way to confirm that
it's just
they said it and so oh who would love
this is a
this is a a murderer and sex offender
well he wouldn't lie about this
and of course even if we could confirm
that they really do identify as women
that wouldn't make a damn bit of
difference because they still don't
belong in women's prisons because
they're not women
but the point is that a lot of these
guys they don't even really identify as
women
they identify as far as just saying oh
yeah i'm a woman
in fact if you're a violent male
criminal in a place like california
why wouldn't you at this point just come
out and say uh yeah i'm a woman too
so send me the women's prison
that's what a lot of them are doing and
uh we have to respect their
self-identity
all right next this is from la mag it
says former
southern california congresswoman katie
hill has been dealt another blow in her
lawsuit against her ex-husband and two
media companies
for publishing nude photos of her
without consent
on wednesday los angeles superior court
judge yolanda orozco
ordered hill to pay british tabloid the
daily mill 103
000 in attorney fees and 1100
in costs this follows or zoko's
april ruling to dismiss the mail as a
defendant in the case in which hill sued
the paper along with ex-husband
kenny heslap and conservative media
outlet red state arguing that
publishing the compromising photos uh
allegedly provided by heslap constituted
revenge
porn which is illegal in 46 states um
at the time the judge declared that
hill's nude image could be published
against her will because they were a
matter of public issue or public
interest
which spoke to hill's character and
qualifications for her position
so this is actually kind of shocking
this is a judge in
california los angeles judge
coming down against a uh
a former democratic lawmaker
and a female judge too who's claiming
that she's
the victim of a sexist attack and
revenge porn and everything and the
judge is saying that that katie hill
has to pay the daily mail the daily mail
which published the nude photos
katie hill has to pay them a hundred
grand rather than the other way around
is it the right ruling i would say yes
absolutely
uh katie hill tweeted and said a judge
just ordered me to pay the daily mail
more than a hundred thousand dollars for
the privilege of them publishing nude
photos of me
obtained from an abuser the justice
system is broken
broken for victims our fight continues
please chip in if you can and then of
course there's a link for the
fundraising page um
this is another one of the situations
where if you want to know what the right
thing is just
imagine the same situation but with the
identities mitch
switched around a little bit make it
make a few little minor al alterations
and imagine that this is a male lawmaker
let's make him a republican also a male
republican lawmaker
who was involved in a sexual
relationship with a staffer
significantly younger than himself and
those photos
leaked to the media and were published
would there be any notion
that they shouldn't have been published
or that he's the victim now and should
be paid money because of it
no everyone katie hill included would be
saying
no this is a sex scandal you're a
lawmaker
what you did was unethical at best if
not illegal
and this is the evidence of it and it is
it's it's the public it's public
interest the public has a right to know
that you're doing this
remember these are the same people who
for years prior to the katy hill case
had and this was the whole really whole
basis of the metoo movement
they had said that you know consent is
not
just a matter of someone of of both
partners
agreeing verbally to do a certain thing
what they've told us
is that even if you get con verbal
agreement it may still be a form of
sexual assault because
of power dynamics and so if you have
power if you're in a position of power
over someone else
and they agree to be involved in a
sexual relationship it can still be rape
or sexual assault
because they weren't in a position to
say no
that's what we were told many
men have had their lives destroyed
rightly or wrongly
based on that logic well
applies here too by their logic katy
hill's a sexual abuser
by their logic by her logic and this
these photos were evidence of that all
right next
the state of florida is free and uh
and open and having a blast has been for
a while
but the left can't admit that so it's
always funny to see the lengths they go
to in order to make it
seem like florida is some kind of
dystopia
you know for example jimmy kimmel who um
and i'm not just saying that this is
jimmy kimmel or not jimmy fallon i get
them confused yeah jimmy kimmel
i'm not just saying this because of his
politics but i i have i have never
heard him tell a funny joke i don't
really get the whole jimmy kimmel thing
um but he uh here's him on a show last
night
talking about florida and yeah he's
making a quote-unquote joke
but listen now to what he says about
florida in america's north korea the
sunshine
state from time to time we enjoy taking
a look at what's going on and tonight we
are doing it again
in a governor desantis edition of this
week in florida
i am proud to be here today in the
everglades as we kick off registration
for the 2021 python challenge
participants who remove the most pythons
and who capture the longest pythons
will receive prizes
unfortunately all the prizes are python
so it's a
it's a python-a-thon going on there in
florida
uh so i mean the only joke there is just
oh look at these look at these
hicks but isn't that funny what are they
doing catching pythons
well by the way just so you know uh the
it's it's actually it's not
it's not funny it's nice i'm not saying
it's not funny oh that's not funny like
i'm offended it's just not
funny it's uh they're catching the
pythons because pythons are an invasive
species
species in the everglades and they've
been introduced i guess by
pet owners who got pythons from why
would you ever want a python
or a snake of any kind as a pet and i'm
not even afraid of
of snakes like i am of spiders but what
what do they do they just lie there what
do you
like what kind of bond are you
developing with a snake but anyway pet
owners they get the python and realize
you know i don't know if this makes the
best pet
and they release it out into the wild
and now they become an invasive species
and are wreaking havoc on the ecosystem
um
so this is not only makes sense for them
to do this down there in florida to
incentivize people to go out and find
these pythons and destroy them
but it's also environmentally conscious
it's it's
eco-friendly it's about protecting the
ecosystem
but before that jimmy kimmel says that
florida is america's north korea
what like i get these trying to make a
joke
but the joke has to have some basis in
reality or it's not funny
um florida is america's north korea
florida is now and has been
the most open and free state in the
country
it's open it's free people are having a
good time
at north korea what
no that would be an analogy that works
for states that were locked down for a
year
and you had to get permission from the
government to get like a permission slip
to go walk your dog outside for 25
minutes okay that would be a north korea
type situation
florida is america that's like saying
it's like saying um
uh yeah know i went to gordon to golden
corral the other day
it's like america's ethiopia
no it's the opposite of that is that
supposed to be the joke
they just can't bring themselves to
admit
that they they everything worked out
well in florida
it worked out better than it than it did
in almost any other state
they can't and they hate that you know
you have to understand people like jimmy
kimmel
they are so angry
that florida was not hit as hard as
places like
new york they wish that thousands of
more floridians had died
they'd be happy
okay and i'm not this this this is just
the fact
if if the coronavirus were to come
surging back suddenly in florida
tomorrow
and 20 000 people died in two weeks
in florida jim someone like jimmy he
would be ecstatic
he would have trouble containing his
enthusiasm
he wishes that that had happened and
he's so upset that it didn't
that goes for almost everyone else in
media too
all right what else do we got here um
right i'll mention this as well this is
from the daily wire also it says pop
singer ricky martin
said he haven't heard much about him in
the last 20 years or so but
uh ricky martin said he still suffers
from ptsd from a 20-year-old interview
he did with barbara walters in which she
inquired about his sexuality
speaking to people to commemorate the
month of june uh what some people refer
to as pride month
the living la vida loco singer said he
gets a fit of anxiety when he reflects
upon the
interview with barbara walters though
ricky martin openly declared his
sexuality in 2010 rumors swirled prior
to his coming out
um and so he was asked about it and now
he says uh
when she asked the question i felt
violated because i was just not ready to
come out i was very afraid
there's a little ptsd with that
and i'm only bringing this up because
this is something people really need to
stop doing
and i've talked many times
about how you know people use these
these mental health terms and just throw
them around like they're nothing
and uh and that's the same thing with
ptsd people are claiming to have
suffered trauma
we've heard it from aoc she suffered
trauma because people uh
people trespassed in a building next to
her own building
and you hear this kind of phrase a lot
oh yeah i got a little bit of ptsd from
that a little smidge of pt
no that's not how it works you don't
have a little smidge a little sliver of
trauma
trauma is real ptsd is real
people can suffer real traumatic events
and it can affect them for the rest of
their lives
it can all it can alter their minds in
such a way that it's
it's like it's permanent scar tissue on
the mind
um that certainly can happen
and we can all think of many types of
legitimately traumatizing events that a
person can suffer
a lot of legitimately traumatizing
events happen in the context of war it's
why you hear about
people coming home from war and
suffering ptsd all of that is real
but um no every uncomfortable situation
is not traumatic even if it's really
uncomfortable
or embarrassing you know
every every time you're you're made to
feel a little bit of pain whether
emotional or physical it's not that's
not trauma
but of course we're also told that
you're never allowed to question
anybody's trauma
if someone says they suffer trauma you
can't question it
no i think you definitely can especially
if someone comes in announces
if they don't announce it it's not it's
none of our business but if they
announce it and say oh i'm
i'm uh i suffered trauma i'm a trauma
victim
you have every right to say oh well what
what happened
and if they tell you i was asked an
uncomfortable question
you know or some someone said something
to me i didn't like
if that's the answer i i think you are
well within your rights to say no you're
not you're not traumatized actually
you're not that's not trauma you do not
get trauma from that
okay that's called being uncomfortable
it's unfortunate we all go through it
that's not trauma
you what you are see this is this is
called being weak
okay being unable to deal with
uncomfortable situations
that's weakness you're weak
being traumatized by actually traumatic
events
that's not weakness that's human any
human would be
all right let's go now to uh we'll go
ahead to
reading the youtube comments let's
first of all this is dana says i am one
of those women who was lied to regarding
abortion i had an abortion when i was 18
and another when i was 21 i was lied to
by everyone including my own mother
i don't blame anyone but myself for my
own decisions however and i live every
day of my life with regret
i pray to god for his forgiveness and to
look over the
two babies whose lives i needlessly
ended i've since had a daughter who's
now a teenager i've shared my story with
her in hopes that she never makes the
same mistakes
thank you for reading my story um well
thank you for sharing it dana speaking
of
traumatic events okay this is something
that really does this this there are
many women who are suffering this kind
of trauma
um and many women who as i mentioned
yesterday will talk about it like dana
is here
but uh they're not listened to which is
another
theme on the show um
but
and this is why when we talk about
abortion
you know i think the primary villains
i point first and foremost and of course
we're all we're all responsible for our
own actions
and whatever we do we're you know the
responsibility comes to us
but with abortion you know there is this
con concerted
highly funded effort conspiracy really
at the highest levels of society and the
abortion industry itself is a billion
dollar industry
and they put a lot of money and a lot of
time and they've gotten very good
at exploiting the fears of young women
who go in
there and the first thing they tell
young women
and we heard it from paxton yesterday it
was being celebrated for her bravery
for talking about how her life will be
over if she has a kid and she'll need to
get abortion if she can't get an
abortion then her life is over
um and as i said i don't i don't really
i don't really blame her for holding
that point of view because this she's
like what's 17 18 years old and this is
what she's been told her whole life
and probably by her parents as well i
would guess could be wrong about that
but
very powerful forces in society have
invested a lot into convincing her of
that
and so women go into these clinics and
uh they're given
the message they get is one of just
total hopelessness
and fear they've got all these
fears and anxieties already which are
understandable especially if you're a
young person
unmarried you're pregnant um
you've got all those fears and anxieties
and then you go into the abortion clinic
and what do they do they don't try to
allay those fears they exploit them
they say oh yeah you feel like your
life's over because it's pregnancy
you're right
it is
and so for me i point to uh the
responsibility lying first and foremost
with with the clinics who are exploiting
women like dana um
all right let's go now to evan evans
says only in america can a woman with
the last name
cortez lecture the rest of us for having
ancestors who colonized people
i always have the same thought whenever
alexandra casa cortez comes up
but i hesitate to make it because i
think hernan cortez is one of the
greatest heroes of history
so i i've been giving aoc way too much
credit to draw that
connection um
but he was a colonizer that's for sure
there's no doubt about that
turns out not all colonizers are bad
and when you've got a colonizer a
conquistador
um who is
who is defeating a civilization
which enslaves and murders
and decapitates thousands and thousands
of innocent people every year
that's a good thing the aztec empire
as evil as the nazis
they're in that category they didn't
kill as many people because they didn't
have the same kind of
technology the same capability to do it
uh you know they were killing people by
one at a time
laying them down on a stone slab and
cutting their hearts out
it takes a little bit longer to do but
um
yeah the the the day that the aztec
empire
fell should be one that we celebrate
that should be a that should be a
worldwide global holiday
let's see kyle says matt what are your
thoughts on the legalization of
psychedelics like
silasabin i haven't even heard of that
what do i think about legalizing it i
think that's a terrible idea
um william says i've never wanted a
child because i'm selfish i enjoy free
time and the ability to travel a lot but
since watching this program more and
hearing your beautiful stories and views
on fatherhood i will
have at least one child well see that's
encouraging i like hearing things like
that
and but you know something william first
of all we're all all human beings are
selfish naturally
and uh that's that's a that's a an
inclination we all have that we have to
fight against we don't we don't want to
say it's natural and give into it but
it's something you have to struggle
against
um as as for men i think
you know it's it's it's more
sort of natural for young women to have
this deep craving
for motherhood and of course they've got
they now have society telling them they
shouldn't crave that they shouldn't want
that
instead they should desire you know
professional success and
and and they should dream rather than
dreaming of having a baby they should
dream of sitting in a cubicle because
that's the ultimate
you know that's that's the pinnacle of
human existence right there
um but for men
you know and there are some men who have
grown up desiring that
i think there are probably fewer men
um which is why but and yet
it's something that men should do it's
something that most most men should do
is have kids and be a father that's why
i think we need to introduce again this
concept of
of duty of responsibility
and as a man you have certain duties and
certain responsibilities
that you should accept and most men
are called not all but most men are
called to be husbands and fathers
once again i emphasize not all but most
that is ultimately where where you're
where you will find your purpose whether
you realize it or not
and it's also where you're going to find
your fulfillment and your happiness
whether you realize it or not
and it's hard to realize it because when
you're a young guy and let's if you're
living alone or something or you're
living in your parents house and
whatever and your your whole life is
just really self-centered and it's hard
to imagine
how you could possibly find any
enjoyment
in living a life of service to another
person because that's so foreign to your
own experience
um but you have to accept that that you
know that is the truth
and it's a responsibility we have as men
and embrace it
and then once you're in it you discover
that okay oh okay
this is how you enjoy it it's hard to
know until you're in it
now checking in with true bill uh you
know what i'm i tend to be a forgetful
person
in general and so i have this problem
and i know a lot of people do
where you sign up for different
subscription services and then you
forget
which you've signed up for along with
forgetting your passwords to all that
stuff as well so it's just a whole mess
that's why you need true build truebill
is the smartest way to manage your
finances it's a very easy to use
app you can review your current charges
in one place
you can cancel subscriptions directly
through the app and that's an important
part of this because a lot of those
subscriptions you forget about you
you're not you forgot about them because
you're not using them and you're just
wasting that money
you might as well just be burning it in
the front yard truebill has a variety of
tools to help customers improve their
finances
you can create a monthly budget and
expenses you can track and evaluate your
savings goals
you can get push notifications when
you're getting close to going over your
budget
all of that um truebill works with many
of the nation's top providers to
negotiate and lower your bills people
think they spend around 80 bucks a month
on subscriptions but actually they spend
closer to 200
a month because they're just not keeping
track of it the average person saves
720 per year with truebill get started
today at truebill.com
matt take control of your finances and
start saving at truebill.com that's
truebill.com
and when it comes to exposing the left
for the liars they are ben shapiro is
commonly known as the best man for the
job
and if you want i thought i was known as
the best man for the job that'd be
second best and if you want to hear him
do it in 15 minutes or less
then you're in for a treat because every
saturday an audio an audio episode of
his new series debunked
uh it comes out and you don't want to
miss if you haven't seen any of the
shows or
listen to any of them you don't want to
miss it because it's just very well done
daily wire members can get the full 10
episode first season over at
dailywire.com
if you're not already a member you can
get 20 off today with code debunked
while the discount lasts tomorrow the
audio episode on
pro-abortion propaganda drops that's one
that i'll be i'll certainly be listening
to i hope you do as well
where ben destroys the left's moral and
scientific reasoning for abortion and
discusses why a life begins at
conception
you don't want to miss that make sure
you listen now let's get to our daily
cancellation
today for our daily cancellation we go
on a journey
and we'll no doubt find many people to
cancel along the way it starts
right where i most want to be up in the
sky with the unidentified aerial
phenomena
otherwise known as ufos the headlines
that we've seen regarding this subject
over the past 12 hours have been
seemingly designed to cause
me emotional trauma speaking of trauma
here's the new york times
headline quote government report finds
no evidence
ufos were alien spacecraft
i'm starting to feel some ptsd many
other headlines making the same
declaration now i want to read a little
bit of this times article
to you and and please note how the
headline is supposedly that there's no
evidence of aliens
but the real news to me is quite a bit
different here's what it says
american intelligence officials have
found no evidence that aerial phenomena
witnessed by
navy pilots in recent years are alien
spacecraft but
they still cannot explain the unusual
movements that have mystified scientists
and the military
according to senior administration
officials briefed on the findings of a
highly anticipated government report
the report determines that the vast
majority of more than 120 incidents over
the past two decades did not
originate from any american military or
other advanced u.s government technology
that determination would appear to
eliminate the possibility that navy
pilots who reported seeing unexplained
aircraft
might have encountered programs the
government meant to keep secret
but that's about the only conclusive
finding in the classified intelligence
report
and while forthcoming unclassified
version expected to be released to
congress by june 25th
will present a few other firm
conclusions or rather few other firm
conclusions
senior officials uh briefed on the
intelligence conceded
that the very ambiguity of the findings
meant the government could not
definitively rule out theories that the
phenomenon
observed by military pilots might be
alien spacecraft
okay so what's the real headline here it
seems to me the headline is
that this technology definitely is not
our own
our government has no idea where it's
from and they can't rule out the
possibility that it originates from a
different solar system
so okay so no the headline is they've
ruled out
one explanation and they didn't rule out
the alien explanation
so we had a few possible explanations
for this
i don't know three or four one of them
is now gone and it's not the alien one
is still on the table
we're still alive alien believers we're
still in business
now call me crazy but the government
can't rule out possibility that
mysterious foreign technologies from
outer space
is bigger news than the government has
no direct evidence of aliens
now both are true of course but the
former headline seems to capture the
news a little bit better in my opinion
now i don't want to focus today on the
alien hypothesis only i focused on that
plenty i'll continue to give
uh top give to provide top-notch alien
content to you
in the future as we await the report
which by the way
i did realize a couple days ago to my
horror that
if this report comes out on on june 25th
i'm not going to be here i'm going on
vacation at the end of the month
and i'll be gone for you know like eight
or nine days
it'll be just my luck if the damn report
comes out
like on the first day of my vacation
because you know if i'm hearing the
report comes out we're doing a week on
aliens
oh yes it's happening
that'll be just my luck you know what's
gonna we're gonna i'm gonna go on
vacation the alien report comes out
and i'm gonna have to say to my wife
listen i gotta go
i have something i need to do and i'm
going to drive back here
and leave her wherever we are so we can
talk about aliens i'm sure she'll
understand
remember like i told you my wife is a
big believer in aliens
wink wink now uh anyway for now though
just for the sake of argument i want to
i want to take into consideration
let's just take into consideration this
idea that uh putting aliens aside
that the flying objects may have more
earthly origins so going back to the
times article this is what they say
about that
intelligence officials believe that at
least some of the aerial phenomena could
be experimental technology from a rival
power most likely russia or china
one senior official briefed on the
intelligence said without hesitation the
u.s officials knew it was not american
technology
he said there was more there was worry
among intelligence and military
officials
that china or russia could be
experimenting with hypersonic technology
russia has been investing heavily in
hypersonics believing the technology
offers the ability to evade
american missile defense technology
china has also developed hypersonic
weaponry and included it in military
parades
if the phenomena were chinese or russian
aircraft officials said it would suggest
that two powers
hypersonic research has far outpaced
american military development
now as much as i hate to admit it it
does seem that the
china-russia theory is the is is is
maybe the more likely more plausible
explanation
okay now that doesn't make the more
entertaining
alien hypothesis implausible
you know at least it the the russia
china thing is the more plausible
explanation for some of the sightings
we should keep in mind that there have
been sightings all over the world
um so this is not just one thing we're
talking about it's not as though every
single ufo has to come from the same
place whether that be a place on earth
or elsewhere
but let's really think about the
possibility that a foreign country
likely an adversary an enemy has
developed military technology
so advanced that our military has to at
least entertain the possibility
that it's not even from this planet
this all seems to create a rather
frightening context
for stories like this from the new york
post
it says quote the pentagon defended the
military's diversity and inclusion
training programs amid a torrent of
criticism
saying they're essential for recruiting
the right people in its duty to defend
the nation pentagon spokesman john kirby
was asked during
tuesday's briefing about gop lawmakers
crafting creating sites urging
whistleblowers
in the armed services to expose
progressive diversity training programs
some of which have reportedly deemed
white people quote inherently evil
so that was the question let's listen
now to john kirby's answer explaining
why the military needs to focus on
diversity and inclusion and tolerance
and equity
and why that makes us safer let's listen
some republican lawmakers have been
attacking various efforts on the
diversity inclusion front in the
military complaining about the stand
down early
order earlier this spring some have
started a system on social media for
active duty troops to file complaints
about the so-called
woke media military what is your
observation
or comment on that well these are
members of congress jennifer we respect
their
uh rights and their responsibilities we
certainly respect the
the oversight that the congress provides
um
i'm not going to comment on any specific
one initiative
that that members of congress might be
doing i think that's more appropriate
for them to speak to what i can speak to
uh is what we're really focused on here
at the department and that's defending
the nation
um and that means putting in place
uh the right resources uh the right
strategies the right operational
concepts to
to to do that around the world
so diversity and inclusion are essential
to defending our nation he says
and he's indeed accurately communicating
the defense department's operating
principle in fact as the dod affiliated
website military one source explains in
a recent article quote
the diverse makeup of the armed forces
is one of its greatest assets when
service members of different races
ethnicities religions sexual
orientations and other identities
unite for a common mission the result is
a stronger and more effective force to
ensure continued progress
the dod has established the independent
defense advisory committee on diversity
and inclusion in the armed forces
this committee will continue the work of
examining any and all issues that will
improve
equal opportunity diversity and
inclusion in the military
diverse and inclusive ranks are
essential to morale force cohesion
and readiness now as always
there is no attempt to provide evidence
supporting the assertion that a diverse
and inclusive military is more effective
whenever anyone in a position of
authority is put on the spot about this
they always dissemble they obfuscate as
the pentagon spokesman did in the clip
we just played
they start talking about how the
military needs to find the best people
for the job etc
and yeah they do that's the point but
what they don't explain is how the
military finds the most talented and
competent people for the job
by hiring and recruiting based on
something other than
talent and competence if you care more
about
finding the best people then you would
simply recruit and train
the best people whatever they look like
whatever sex they might be
if you end up with a diverse military as
a byproduct of your focus on skill and
competence
then great if you let's say end up with
a military
comprised almost entirely of straight
men that's great too
however it shakes out is fine because
the people you have on board are the
best of the best
diversity again should be a byproduct if
anything
not the goal not a litmus test
but that's not how our military's top
brass see it
they're putting out ads featuring
sorority girls with lesbian moms and the
cia is bragging about hiring women with
anxiety disorders
and they're sending military members and
intelligence officers to mandatory
sensitivity training courses and
critical race theory brainwashing
sessions
because they believe that the ultimate
mission of these institutions
is to support progressive social causes
that's what they believe
meanwhile china and russia are finding
the very best and toughest people
that their nations have to offer and
setting them to the task of defending
their country
and expanding their empires and even
potentially
developing technology that looks like
it's from another galaxy
in comparison with that we are
committing an act of national suicide
we're not the first nation to kill
itself but we may be the first to do it
so intentionally
and abruptly and quickly and through
such bizarre
means in short
i would like to once again send out a
plea to the aliens
to take me with you before you leave to
go back to your home planet
because i know eventually you're leaving
because
you got to be sick of this and please
allow my wife and kids to come too
i haven't consulted them about this but
i think they'll adjust and
ultimately they'll thank me for it and
everyone will be better off
as for who i'm canceling well
i guess the pentagon the media for
continuing to doubt the
alien hypothesis just canceling everyone
which is
which is how i like to to end uh every
week on a friday
and we'll leave it there thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nikka geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters
the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
20 21. hey everybody this is andrew
clavin host of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets
started so come on over to the andrew
clavin show and laugh your way through
the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin